All right,
we're live.
What's up?
How are weird,
right?
Yeah.
Here we go.
Nice to meet you man.
Thank you.
Yeah,
I can't believe we've never met.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
I've been a fan of your music for a long
time,
so it's Kinda cool to see you in person.
I've worked out conversely,
so it's cool.
So I mean,
I don't mean to just jump right into
this,
but it kind of freaked me out that your
have involvement in pro wrestling.
The own.
The NWA.
Yeah.
The national wrestling alliance,
the oldest brand in the world I was
working for TNA was president for a hot
second.
Then I got fired.
And you were President of TNA.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's a crazy story.
I don't know how much you want to get
into that.
Well,
you know,
Dixie Carter own TNA.
I knew her through the years.
I used to go to shows and stuff like
that and um,
and at some point they approached me
about investing.
I said No.
Then they offered me a job.
I started working for the company.
Then they would,
they have started having money problems.
They started putting money in and
through the contrivance of all that,
then I started getting more power in the
company and putting in more money.
So then it became like,
well,
if I'm going to put in all this money
and I'm going to have all this power,
I want to run the show.
They basically said that was cool.
And then the minute I had the spot,
it was like,
game of thrones.
They all started trying to kill me off
and then,
you know,
wrestling's weird because you have this
weird mix of reality and fantasy and
it's hard sometimes to know where one
thing and the fans get into both the
behind the scenes and the fantasy.
So no one's quite sure sometimes where
the blur is.
And he had got pretty crazy for a while.
There's a lawsuit.
I'm a real lawsuit sued.
I sued,
and this is a quick funny thing.
Um,
people continually write that I lost the
lawsuit.
I never lost the lawsuit.
I lost one of the motions which led to
them mean negotiating.
And we settled out of court.
But the judge,
the contract that they signed,
that would have allowed me to take over
the company under the,
under the motion that I had filed,
the judge basically dismissed my motion
because the contract they had signed
with me was illegal under Tennessee law
even though a Tennessee lawyer had
negotiated on the company's behalf and
signed it.
Whoa.
That sounds like some double cross
wrestling type guy.
So it'd be like
you did a contract with me and then I
sued you.
And then the judge says,
well,
even though Joe had a California lawyer
sign,
it's illegal under California law.
So therefore the contracts meaningless.
It was bizarre.
How does one go from smashing pumpkins
pro wrestling and then go so deep that
you're like an owner?
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's pretty wild and unexpected for a
lot of people,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I get that a lot.
Um,
and I've learned and I've actually,
I've actually learned over time,
it's just best to keep the world
separate because the music fans don't
want to hear anything about the
wrestling.
I mean,
they just don't want to.
They just,
they,
they get the a that I'm a bit goofy,
but they just don't want to hear about
the wrestling thing they asked.
They asked the worlds to be kept
separate.
Did they ever get mad at you?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You know,
and you can appreciate that.
It kills the gimmick.
They want me to be this gothic vampire
guy or whatever,
and then it's like.
And then,
and then there's pro wrestling.
It's just,
it just totally kills the gimmick.
It's really funny though.
I think it's awesome.
I love it when people just get into what
they like.
Well that's something I appreciate about
you.
You know what I mean?
Like I've watched where you guys go deep
dives and mma and other things.
It's like,
I think it's cool to have multiple
interests.
I at the renaissance man thing.
Yeah.
Well I think for,
for some reason people shy away from
them because they think folks are going
to be confused.
I don't care.
Yeah.
Good for you.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
no,
I'd grown up in Chicago.
There was a really rich wrestling
history in Chicago growing up and my,
my,
my great grandmother watch wrestling.
I mean it was like I grew up in,
at four years old,
I'm watching Dick,
the bruiser on television and this was
also the era of hockey fights and I'm
roller derby.
Oh,
road debbie.
So we'd watch hockey,
pro wrestling,
you know,
it was in the family and then later I
found out that my other great
grandmother also watch wrestling,
so both sides of the family,
both her great grandmother sweatshirt
wrestling.
So it's just in the blood I guess.
We liked that we liked the car and have
at all.
Well,
I'm always amazed at Roller Derby.
I've never made like a serious comeback.
They tried,
they kind of did the,
you know,
the tattooed girl's doing roller Derby
hipstery type thing.
It had a moment there.
Well,
I know I had a friend who was into it
and she was that type.
I just thought,
well that seems like something that
would catch on today.
Yeah.
They transitioned from like Roller Derby
to suicide girls.
Yeah.
It was like to get a little hotter,
that girl,
you can be thick and be a roller derby
girl.
You could,
you could eat all the carbs you liked,
but didn't roller derby back in the day
was huge.
Yeah.
I mean they were doing like packed
arenas and stuff.
That's crazy.
Well,
it's fun to watch.
It's pretty wild.
Yeah.
I only see him go after each other and
skating around.
It's pretty aggressive.
It's fun.
It's like racing plus fighting and hip
checking each other,
you know,
it's early days memory,
but I remember thinking,
you know,
there's something sort of hot about the
whole thing.
I think especially in Chicago,
the women's Roller Derby was bigger than
the men's,
so that says something.
Yeah.
I didn't even know there was men's
roller derby,
like thinking of men's Roller Derby.
I,
I'm completely drawing a blank.
I always associated it with like tough
women.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
I think the women's thing actually had
some sort of staying power where the
men's,
I think it didn't have the same alert or
maybe.
Yeah.
I guess,
uh,
you're,
you're my age.
You remember killer Kowalski Course?
Yeah,
I remember watching that when I was a
kid in Boston watching it on the,
on regular tv,
you know,
that those guys were great.
I mean,
it's a golden age.
It's like anything you can go back and
sort of romanticize it.
And um,
I think that's part of what we're trying
to do is,
that's the cool thing about the nw is we
actually possess that history and,
and so our job is to sort of update it,
you know,
to bring
it,
to bring that tough guy thing back into
the modern world in a way that doesn't
insult the audience's intelligence.
So the Nwa is that older than the wwe I
1948 is the Nwa.
And the cool thing about the end was
history was you had all these rival
promoters,
including the mcmahons in the northeast
that eventually sort of formed a kind of
ad hoc association to create a better
business in essence,
get everybody on the same page.
And what they would do is they named one
champion the champion,
rotate through the different
territories,
come in and take on the whoever was the
local guy,
they build up the local guy and then a
guy like rick flair would come in and
beat the local guy and it would always
be like a bit of a scrum.
And then he'd come back for a second,
there would be a cage match and then
rick flair would move onto the next
territory.
And that's how those guys rotate around
and everybody made more money.
Wow.
And then the government got involved at
different points because there was
collusion.
There you go.
There's ric flair with our belt.
Actually I follow him on instagram.
Yeah.
I mean Rick,
Rick's rick in a dusty,
dusty Rhodes,
or are probably the two most prominent
chance that the Nwa had.
So just to be the owner of that history
is so humbling for me as a fan.
It's like,
wow,
that is so cool.
Yeah,
that's pretty wild actually.
He's,
uh,
he's quite a character and still is
like,
even on instagram stories,
stories are legendary.
Stories are absolutely wondering,
30 for 30 just came out about them and
I'm hearing it's like one of the best
ones ever made.
Just the day to day,
maybe two days ago.
Oh cool.
Then I,
and I'm not trying to speak for rick,
but you know,
there's,
there's an example of somebody where
it's like the persona and the real life
person sort of blurred.
Right.
And it's hard to figure out who was who
at any given time that you know,
that's the case.
Like dice clay.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
He used to be Andrew Silverstein and the
dice man was a character needs to do on
stage as he now is.
He now become 100 percent all Manson's
that my friend had friends,
Marilyn Manson.
He's the same way.
It's like they become,
they become the gimmick at some point
and sometimes you're not sure who you're
talking to,
but,
but at some point you also have to
respect that that's so intrinsic to
their world that maybe it's almost
easier just to become the gimmick.
Right.
Instead of having to live.
You don't have to turn it on and off.
Yeah.
I'm the other way,
I've,
I've gone out of my way to kill the
gimmick,
which really it actually hurts business
and people get mad at me because they
wanted to know they want the fantasy
guy,
but I can't live like that.
It's impossible for me.
So they want you to be almost like a
caricature,
like a Moody Salads,
rumbling a,
you know,
whatever,
you know.
That's why a lot of this stuff on me
that's clickbait is based on the
character that I both created and people
want me to play.
Wow.
That's like one of the biggest memes of
last year.
It was about a year ago was like me at
Disneyland.
I don't know if you've heard about that.
So it's classic.
I was on a ride and somebody took a
picture of me on the ride and for
whatever reason I just don't look happy
at that particular moment.
And I got this great,
this great to infect the guy in the
room.
My tour manager Jug was the guy sitting
next to me in the photo and a.
There you go look.
And it was like massive viral,
like that's perfect.
And I had a great date,
like I met,
I met,
I met tons of fans,
I took pictures with everyone.
I love Disneyland.
I had this great day and that became
like this massive thing of like see,
he's miserable even at Disneyland.
That's hilarious.
That's funny.
What a perfect picture.
Right?
Right.
So,
and even ended up on family guy say,
look,
that's very funny man.
That's very funny.
That's got to be exhausting.
Like having all these expectations that
aren't necessarily,
that don't totally aligned with who you
really are.
A,
it used to be because I felt like I
dunno is the keeper of my image or
something.
I felt this responsibility to sort of
manage it and that's when I just let it
go.
No,
well,
sorry to interrupt you,
but it's like at some point I decided
crazy was better for business.
Like I'm okay with people thinking.
No,
it's,
it's totally okay because I'm the exact
opposite of nuts.
You have to be.
You're certainly eccentric.
Yeah,
that's fine.
You know,
I come from a long line of eccentrics.
I mean my father was a drug dealing gun
toting musician.
Was It really madman?
Yeah,
yeah.
Drug dealing.
Oh yeah.
What kind of drugs?
You name it.
Really?
Oh yeah.
Wow.
I mean it's a,
it's a like quick stories.
Like when I was a kid,
my father was a musician,
so I remember I used to like,
I wasn't allowed to touch his guitars
but I was allowed to look at them.
So I remember one day I was walking past
the bedroom and I saw a guitar case
under the bed and I was like,
oh,
I wonder what that is.
Did he get a new guitar?
So I went and slipped the thing out and
I flipped it open.
It was,
it was a sawed off shotgun in a guitar
case.
Just lay in there,
you know,
in the house or you know,
I'd go to open something.
It would be like 10 pounds of weed,
you know,
it's just this system.
That was the,
that was the world I grew up in.
Where did you grow up?
Outside of Chicago.
About an hour outside.
Wow.
But yeah,
my dad,
my dad got arrested a bunch of times and
massive bus and drug.
It's just crazy.
Then got people knocking on the door in
the middle of the night and,
and getting shot at and my dad says he's
been shot at nine times.
Never hit.
No,
that's luck.
Stabbed two or three times.
Jesus.
My favorite story with,
uh,
my,
one of my favorite stories,
my father was,
um,
he was doing a drug deal and or he was
buying drugs and like,
so he stops and wearing the guy got in
the car and then the guy pulled out a
gun and stuck it in his ribs in and did
like give me all your money.
And my dad looked and said,
kill me base because he was unhappy.
So he figured I fucking just,
he said,
just kill me.
And the guy,
the guy flipped out and left the car and
he told you all this.
Oh yeah.
I got a lot of these stories.
Post-Haste yeah.
Is he still around?
Oh yeah.
He's still around.
He's still kicking.
What was it for him,
like seeing you as a son?
As a weird thing?
Because in the beginning he was very
dismissive of the music.
Yeah.
He was not supportive of me playing the
guitar.
He and my father was a great musician.
I mean,
I mean that with great sincerity.
My father was truly talented and I'm in
the beginning he was not supportive at
all,
didn't want me to play the guitar,
didn't want me involved in music.
And even after I put out my first album,
which went on to be at the time was like
the most successful independent album
ever released.
So it wasn't like an insignificant
moment in my life.
My Dad would just kind of shrugged her
shoulders,
was like,
it's okay,
you know,
it was like,
what are you talking about?
Like wow,
you know,
if you know,
my earliest guitar heavy,
there's cool stuff,
Solos.
And he was just like,
yeah,
it wasn't until my second album in the
band blew up.
Then he started kind of changed his
tune.
Then he became more supportive.
Then he got really weirdly jealous who.
And then he started doing weird things
like he call me and it'd be like,
um,
if you need me to write you any songs,
like I'm like number one.
And he's like,
he's asking me to write songs.
It was so weird,
but then he was also a lot of drugs and
so there was that,
you know,
there's that interweave of like and
weird stuff like,
you know,
um,
one day he calls me and he's like,
my dad always played this cool 19,
64,
purple flying b.
That was like his guitar,
you know,
and my,
my dad,
to me it was like a star and he still is
in my mind.
So,
um,
he told me one day,
you know,
when I die,
I'm going to give you my guitar.
And then fast forward four years later,
he calls me up.
He's like,
yeah,
I'm gonna.
Put this guitar and Ebay.
So he said,
you do you want to buy it?
No,
I had to buy the guitar.
You're supposed to get what he does.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
It's just weird stuff like that.
It's been a lot of that.
So anybody who's grown up in that,
those types of situations,
it's not talking about.
It's like wacky world.
You're never quite sure what angle was
going on because the need for money,
depending on what situation is going on,
you know?
Yeah.
But you weren't reinforced.
You reinforce this idea that I've always
had that.
Everyone that I know that's interesting
came from a fucked up childhood.
I couldn't argue against it.
It's hard because.
Do you have children?
I have one son.
Yeah.
He's.
He's just going to be too.
It's for me,
it's,
it's so.
It's a conflict because I take care of
my kids and I'm around and I give him a
lot of love there.
Not fucked up and I'm like,
my kid's going to be boring.
I think all of my friends,
all of them come from fucked up
household chaos and they created the
pressure.
Created these diamonds.
Yeah.
There's something to be said for the
adversity and my dad would even say to
me weird things like,
it's good you had a fucked up childhood
because it made you successful.
Yeah.
Thinking like I would have preferred
like Disneyland with you.
You know what I mean?
Maybe I wouldn't have been miserable at
Disneyland if it wasn't for you dad.
Man,
I think your story's amazing though.
I mean,
I know it probably sucked growing up
like that,
but damn,
to be able to tell everybody your dad
was his guitar playing tote and drug
deal in psycho.
I mean that's a bad ass story.
Yeah,
there's
this.
I think you'll appreciate this in the,
in the gangster tradition.
So there was this thing that happened
when I was probably about 10 or 12 where
there was a local club and you know,
and my dad played there all the time and
I came back to the House one day and the
house was full of just like smokey
equipment,
like you could smell like smoke,
fire.
And,
and he said,
Oh,
the club burned down.
And so they had ran in the fire or
retrieve the gear,
some kind of story like that.
And so that was the story for years was
he was eating across the street pancakes
at four in the morning and saw the club
burned down.
Years later I heard the real story.
He was in a car with a chick doing
whatever,
and he saw some mob guy walk in the club
with gasoline,
light the club on fire,
so he knew it was arson,
but because he knew it was mob related,
he couldn't say anything and that's
like,
that's like every story is like there's
the real story and the story I got when
I was a kid,
so he ran into the fire just to get
equipment.
Yeah,
I think he ran in and got his guitar.
He was able to save his guitar and then.
And then.
And then of course the police came and
questioned him because they knew he had
was there on the scene or something.
And of course he said I didn't see
anything because he didn't want to die
because of Chicago with the mob.
I mean,
forget about it.
Especially back then in the seventies,
it was like they ran the town,
they got Kennedy elected.
Well,
yeah,
I mean that.
I mean,
the stories about Chicago are legendary.
You know what I mean?
Like people used to come to Chicago back
in the day.
It's a little bit different now.
People come,
PAC man,
the city is so clean,
it's so organized.
It's like,
yeah,
because it's run by,
you know,
Capo is all over the city.
You know,
every ward had its capo and
yes to Congo has is uniquely violent
history and even to this day with,
with what's going on in the south side
with all the gangs,
it's,
it's shocking to me as somebody who was
born in Chicago,
I still live in Chicago,
that it's just like we've normalized
this insane violence in our,
in this community.
We don't even realize.
I think most people have no idea how
much gun violence
those I heard the other day.
I could,
I could be wrong and I'm sure you can
find,
but I think somebody said the other day,
there's been 3,700
shootings in Chicago already this year
and I think we're already over 600 gun
fatalities and this isn't like every
year now.
Wow.
I mean I just,
and even trump at some point flooded out
like maybe they should bring the
national guard.
I wish they would do something.
I just.
Such a dis generational tragedy that
just keeps going and nothing seems to
happen.
Yeah.
And it seems to have a lot of momentum
behind it.
Like the murders they,
they've,
they make people have revenge murders
and then it just piles on top of each
other and it doesn't seem like there's
any,
any stopping it inside.
Well,
here's the thing,
and this is the classic tale.
Now.
It was reported the other day that the
car jackings in Chicago have gone up
like 200 percent and now those
carjackings are filtering into the nice
neighborhoods.
Uh,
so now you're gonna start seeing some
action because now,
now
it's blowing up past the sort of,
you know,
I mean,
look at that,
the shot clock,
a person is shot every two minutes and
20 seconds a person is murdered every 12
hours.
Oh,
two hours and 20 minutes a person is
murdered every 12 hours and 23 minutes.
That's a lot.
Wow.
I mean,
it's my home and I just,
you know,
I have a.
I'm a guy that I met when I was down
there.
He was a driver.
He drove us around and he was saying
that uh,
he used to be a cop and that would
happen was they arrested some of the top
level drug dealers.
I've heard this exact same story and as
soon as they did that there became this
power vacuum.
And then for years I got a little
insight information for years.
What I'd heard is that they had this
sort of like as long as you stay on this
side of the street,
we'll kind of,
we'll look the other way for this,
but you got to keep your people in line
over here.
And I know enough people in the PD that,
that was sort of the general
understanding.
Like even like I remember one time
because I knew somebody who worked in
the,
in the,
in like the gang taskforce as like how
come there's always whores on the bridge
on Friday night.
Like don't you guys see the 50 whores
and the bridge?
And they said,
no,
we,
that's where we tell all the horse to go
so we can protect them.
We'd rather have them there so we can
keep an eye on them.
And we know what's going to happen
anyway so better we control it.
So that was the way Chicago started
operated was like we'll tolerate crime
up to this level in twice a year.
We'll run everybody in just to Kinda
make the,
make it look good in the paper.
And then apparently whatever they did
that created this power vacuum,
that's just what I've heard.
I don't know.
Scott was a former cop and the way he
was describing it was pretty absolute.
He's like,
they made a mistake,
the,
this solution that you were saying of
like kind of like saying,
hey,
keep it over here or keep it under wraps
and we'll arrest a certain amount of
people.
It sounds like maybe that's the only way
to manage it.
Well the one thing I do,
I have heard from people that are in
those communities is that literally the.
And this may be supports.
What you're saying is that the,
the power divisions are like block the
block.
So it's almost like an insurgency where
it's like two blocks versus two blocks
versus one block versus three blocks.
So literally if you're walking on the
wrong side of the street,
it's not even like neighborhood to
neighborhood,
it's like block to block,
which is crazy.
And just growing up in that
neighborhood,
having that be your normal as a child
and then growing into adulthood around
that and having just used to people
getting shot used to shooting people
you.
I mean if there's that many people
getting shot and that many gunshots
going off,
everybody must be common.
I mean it must be common everyone.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's just crazy.
That's just heartbreaking.
It's such a unique town too.
It's an amazing city.
It really is.
Yeah.
I mean we have this weird bare knuckle
history.
Yeah.
And it's still there,
you know?
No,
no amount of yuppies moving and it's
changed as sort of working sort of ethos
while you.
It's sort of symbolized by the food that
giant pizza.
Yeah.
We like to eat depth pizzas.
Insane.
That what you deliver those pizzas,
by the way.
Did you really?
Yeah,
that was one of my gigs.
I bet it builds your arms up heavy.
What?
First time I ate a Chicago deep dish
pizza,
I was like,
okay,
is this really a pizza?
Like what do we see?
This is a casserole.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but it's like tardy people too.
It's like there's something about
Chicago that seems to me to have like
the momentum of the old days still
deeply entrenched in it,
whereas that doesn't seem the case in La
and a lot of other big cities.
Yeah.
It's just like kind of weird Yuppy yuppy
thing.
I call it yet,
but I don't know what you want to call
it,
but if it's like South Park did that
episode where it's like,
it's not like once the whole foods moves
in like everyone's supposed to live a
certain way.
Did you see that episode?
But it's like this funny bit about like
how the whole foods sort of anchors down
this new way of life.
Some kind of like,
you know,
riff on that said it does.
I bet it does in some way.
Yeah.
So it's this idea of sort of like a,
you can drop this homogenous idea of
what modern cultures like in any place
and it will just sort of riff out like a
spore.
Yeah.
It's like we've got the whole foods and
we've got the,
you know,
the starbucks and,
and now we're all going to be nice to
each other or something.
It's like a weird,
you know what I mean?
Like we're all just going to start
behaving better because,
you know,
whatever.
I think I understand the joke.
No,
I do,
you know,
I think uh,
but again saying your environment that
you grew up in this chaos and then
coming from Chicago and coming from,
you know,
the stories you're telling about your
dad that had to contribute to like the,
the deepness and intensity of your
music.
Right?
I Dunno,
I,
I certainly revolted against suburban
life.
Yeah.
I mean the suburban life of that world.
It's just,
I just,
I just couldn't take it.
Yeah,
man.
Just couldn't take it.
The mall,
the mall,
the Strip mall vibe,
whatever.
That was just a rat in a cage,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
the,
well,
the great thing is then I traded one
imprisonment suburbia for,
you know,
rock and roll aesthetics and you know,
who's,
who gets to say who is integral and you
know,
who's cool and not cool.
Oh my God.
That would,
that drove me insane to WHO's selling
out.
Yeah.
I mean the first line of um,
uh,
the first line of our second album is
freak out and given it doesn't matter
what you believe in,
you know,
it's like,
it's like you gotta you gotTa play by
now you've got to play by these rules.
You've got to kiss this ring and you
know,
it's just music.
So He's,
the weird thing too is that people
really enjoy you when they're the only
ones who know about you.
And then as you started getting bigger
and bigger,
they start looking for holes.
Yeah,
we blew that up early though.
We believe that we glued up really
early.
We made a lot of enemies really early,
which is crazy because,
I mean,
the enemies I made in the early
nineties,
I mean,
I still have them.
I mean they're still sort of lurking out
there in various holes.
It's weird.
He's like those,
those,
you know,
inner seen rivalries never end,
between bands or.
It's like I've had weird experiences
with like people not with Nirvana people
but like people who were in the nirvana
world.
There's still like this weird like
because I'm from Pumpkin World,
like pee out sometimes I'll have weird
stuff happen and I'll dig down and find
out.
It was like somebody who used to work in
Nirvana world trying to cut my ankles 27
years later.
Like so weird.
Like so parochial.
The whole Nirvana scene is a very
strange scene.
You know,
whenever the main guy commit suicide and
this oddly conspiratorial way,
did you watch that fucked up movie
that's now a lot of people don't know.
I was sort of around for a lot of that
stuff.
So I know a lot of stuff that I've never
sort of talked about.
So for me watching that stuff is like,
it's a,
it's replaying something I don't want to
replay.
And B,
I know a lot of the stuff is not based
on fact because I was around for a lot
of it and no one's ever talked to me
about it.
So people tried to pimp me out like in a
q and a with fans and asked me questions
like I'm suddenly going to talk about
it.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
That,
that documentary was so strange.
It was like,
how does someone get it
way with that?
Like the recreation's,
like if you weren't there,
you don't know what the fuck they said.
So if you don't know what the fuck they
said and you're putting words in these
actors' mouths and having them play it
out like you're just this,
this should be illegal because you're
kind of.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like your car,
especially when you're talking about a
murder mystery,
you're,
you're saying that it wasn't a suicide.
You're,
you're,
you're at least putting out the idea
that it might be a murderer the way
you're doing it.
And it's by manufacturing words that you
have no idea if they were ever say it's
complete fiction.
Yeah,
yeah,
so like,
that's,
I,
I was around for the before sorta during
and,
and certainly a lot after and I know a
lot of stuff that again,
I know is not in the public domain and
so I,
I go with what I know.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
But it's,
that whole nirvana thing was.
I mean,
I remember the first time I heard
Nirvana,
I was a kid in Boston and this buddy of
mine played it for us and we were,
we'd never heard anything like that.
We were like,
Whoa,
yeah,
I,
this,
this thing just fantastic.
A new thing,
right.
Like a new,
like here's a crazy little Boston
statistic for you.
We weren't played,
it was nirvana,
pumpkin's and bullet Lavolta we played
at that little club.
It was like an art club across from
fenway.
I can't remember what it's called.
Access or,
right.
Yeah,
but you know what I'm talking about.
But yeah,
we played there like,
I don't know,
92 wasn't even sold out.
Oh Wow.
It's like 700 people kind of thing.
That's seven people with an awesome
story.
Yeah.
Yeah,
right.
Wow.
So you're,
you're working with Rick Rubin now?
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Eric's fantastic.
Is that like though for you being like a
guy who's Kinda like,
you kinda controlled everything before,
right?
Yeah,
totally.
So what is it like for you to have Ruben
in the mix and.
Yeah,
well rick's of friends.
So for me it was like I was sort of at a
low point and he kind of picked me up
when I was down so it was like I didn't
mind sort of trusting him with like the
head part of it all kind of like you
deal with that part and I'm just going
to sort of be up to the performer and
the weird guy in the corner and give you
relief.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I felt like it allowed me to focus on
the music and the performance and Sorta
just freed me to just,
you know,
whatever.
Because sometimes you can psych yourself
out.
I don't know if that makes any sense.
Like you can have a really good song,
you know,
it's a good song and then you start
second guessing yourself and they start
thinking,
well maybe this song is not good enough,
and then that'll,
that'll infiltrate into your performance
as opposed to being free.
Like,
Hey,
I've just got a good song and if that
one doesn't work,
I've got another good song.
So letting rick kind of do the picking
and choosing and that's a good take and
that's a good song.
It was just like,
okay,
I'm just going to kind of just go down
this road.
It took me back to sort of a more
innocent way of approaching the work and
I'm very grateful to him for that.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
It's got to be quite a mind fuck to
create something and then practice it
and rehearse it over and over again and
tweak it and mess with it and not know
really,
like not,
not almost not be able to be objective
anymore.
Yeah.
Well the weird thing is is I hope people
can appreciate it.
How.
I mean,
it is like at one point when I.
my ear was really at the ground,
I was able to do that.
I was able to be objective and
subjective,
be the writer and be the producer and I
hit a lot of home runs,
so then you get kind of like,
I know what I'm doing.
Right?
So then when it stops working,
you have two choices.
You can blame yourself,
which is the natural thing you should
do,
or you can blame others and once you
start blaming others,
now you're in this hall of mirrors.
Yeah.
You know,
instead of raising your hand saying,
okay,
I've had a good run.
Now it's like getting a coach or
something like maybe a guy goes on a
losing streak and need spring in a new
coach to say,
I think you need to work on your
offense.
You know what I mean?
Just somebody to tweak you.
Yeah.
But when you're flying a thousand miles
an hour and you're selling gazillions of
records and making all this money and
you're surrounded by a bunch of sick
fence,
they're not going to tell you,
hey man,
you need,
you know,
you needed the doctor to come in and
kind of search,
search,
head out.
Yeah.
So then you start going this way and
then that's when it gets like hall of
Mirrors.
So that's where,
that's where my own Hubris sorta gotten
my own way.
I couldn't accept that I got on a losing
streak and then,
you know,
go to somebody like rick and say,
I need some help.
I need some objective help.
I'm.
Did you feel yourself,
like when you were listening to the
music that you were creating,
did you feel like you were on a losing
streak?
No.
No I couldn't.
I couldn't.
I couldn't intellectually understand why
I was failing.
It didn't make any sense to me.
And sometimes it's just generational.
It's the market changes,
whatever.
It's not personal.
It feels incredibly personal,
which is why it's easier to blame
somebody else.
Like you don't understand the depth of
my,
my work here,
I'm so deep and you know,
you're not following my,
my met a path or say,
you know what I mean?
And look,
it's most,
most entertainment is popular,
right?
I mean you're,
you're a comedian.
I mean it's like if you get them to tell
a bunch of jokes and the audience
doesn't laugh,
whose fault is it?
Well,
the,
the mindfuck of music to me has always
been very fascinating because you guys
create it in like a vacuum or totally.
And then you bring it into the people.
Like when you release an album,
they get it and it's done.
It's like,
Holy Shit,
here it is.
And you know,
big fan plays it for the first time and
they're listening to it that I go on it
like it's,
it's all.
Whereas we have ideas and I need an
audience to create like I need to be
around them.
I can't,
I can only create so much on a laptop.
Most of it has to be like fine tuned.
And so by the time I record something
already,
no.
Yeah,
it's already been tested,
right,
so that's.
Go back to my point,
if you get on a winning streak and
you're,
you're creating things in a bubble and
then they work well then you want to
take all the credit for it.
You forget all the thousand hours in the
bedroom that you listen to Jimi Hendrix
or you know,
Bauhaus or merciful fate or whatever you
know,
like that gave you all these ideas.
You,
you know,
you don't want to give them credit.
You want to be the author of your own
success.
It starts patting you on the back and
yeah.
I'm sorry to interrupt.
I just want to be very introspective in
that regard.
Like you,
you have a very,
I'm a failure with failure would do
that.
Is that when you say failure though,
but you still have massive amounts of
fans are still
DPA expected?
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm weird in that I've always been
willing to talk about the process,
which again is anti gimmick,
but also,
um,
uh,
I,
I've always approached it more like a
performance artist in that I'm after the
bigger message of how work intersects
with fame intersects with personal
feeling intersects with personality and,
and,
and how people perceive things like I
like all that weird Andy Kaufman,
uncomfortability.
That's part of my attraction.
So I've been willing to use myself as
the battering ram,
which is how I ended up becoming a meme,
right?
Because people,
people latch onto these personalities
I've created,
which of course are ancillary to my real
personality,
but they don't.
They don't necessarily want to give me
credit that I'm sort of controller of
the forces at play.
So if I say something dumb,
people assume that I'm dumb.
It's hard for them to assume that I'm
saying something dumb on purpose because
I want a reaction.
Yeah.
When you become a hugely successful
musician and your life becomes touring
big arenas,
doing radio shows,
getting on the bus,
getting on the plane,
all of a sudden,
does it make it difficult to have like
that
time or the.
The actual experiences to continue to
create?
Yes.
Because you get so deoxygenated in the
bubble that you start writing songs
about being on tour.
Yeah.
Like comedians will tell jokes about
airline food.
Yeah,
exactly.
You got to becoming sort of like you're
trying to take people in the insularity
of your experience,
but it's not that interesting.
Right?
At some point it becomes unrelatable.
Well,
I always said that about like A.
I mean there's,
there's a lot of bands,
but some of the great allman brothers or
Leonard Skinner,
like they had a bunch of songs about
leaving,
about getting away from women.
You know,
Lord,
I was born in rambling man.
So yeah,
there was so many songs about just
getting away from women.
Yeah.
The other day I heard that crosby,
stills,
Nash and song.
It's like just a song before I go.
It's all about he's going on tour and
they go to the airport and it's
uncomfortable.
It's like,
it's such a going onto her song.
Yeah.
But it's like,
it's really not that relatable to most
people know to a lot of people.
It's not.
Yeah.
I mean,
skinner had a shitload of those.
They really did have quite a few songs
about like getting the fuck out of
dodge.
They were good.
Such a great band.
Giant fan.
I mean,
they're probably the greatest thing to
ever come out of Florida.
It's arguable,
you know.
I'm trying to think who else came out of
Florida?
Uh,
Jim Brewer.
I thought we were talking about that
already.
Just talking about music.
I don't have anything else when it comes
to music.
Who else?
Pit Bull.
Yeah.
It's uh,
the,
the.
So do you,
did you feel it while it was happening?
Like when you're,
you're doing these mega tours and
everything.
Do you feel like this staleness and the
creation?
Um,
I did.
Yeah.
I think what I tried to do is change
personalities,
change musical directions to reinfuse
things.
And it worked up until a point until my
mother died,
like in 96,
in,
in a,
in a weird three month period.
The drummer left the band,
my mother died and I got a divorce in
like a six month period.
And so I try to use that as fuel to sort
of pivot where I wanted to go musically.
But I wrote this very introspective,
dark record,
which a lot of people really like now.
But at the time it was like so
antithetical to this big rock scene.
Um,
yeah.
And it was castigated for being an
idiot.
And I went from golden child to idiot,
you know,
in one fell swoop.
And
well,
so many great artists are a prisoner of
the early success and rightly so.
You know what I mean?
I,
I have a much greater appreciation for
the zeitgeists effect of the public.
Don't know if that makes any sense.
It's like,
it's like how many.
It's like guys,
did Elvis have three youtubes,
had two or three.
Frank Sinatra had two or three or four.
I mean,
there's something about when it all
seems to make sense,
like the public fascination,
the artists place in time that work
that's being created.
There's a sense of like familiarity,
but also something is happening and
everybody wants to take part in it and
so I have a much greater appreciation
for that moment.
The Ego of the artist wants to Vince
yourself that you're always in that
moment and that's just impossible.
That's just impossible.
There's just no way.
It's just the cyclical nature of
creation.
That's such an important thing to say
for people listening,
for people that struggle with this
themselves.
Here's something like you say that.
Yeah,
it's.
It's actually kind of makes sense.
It's like,
it's like,
it's like a typical example.
It's like falling in love and expecting
to feel that feeling forever.
It's just not gonna happen.
You're not going to feel the same.
No.
I would argue if you are,
there's something wrong,
right?
You haven't matured into a deeper
relationship,
so in the same thing an artist needs to
mature into a deeper relationship with
their work or their relationship with
the public or their relationship with
themselves.
And if you can do that and you look at
great examples.
Johnny cash,
Neil Young,
Tom Petty when they get there,
everybody comes back,
Bob Dylan because they think,
okay,
now you're giving me some new
information.
This isn't just a riff on the thing that
you gave me before.
And um,
and I think the public has shown over
time the willingness and the ability to
follow artists if they're willing,
if they're,
if they're able to go to that place
where they might not something new that
actually is like a cultural contribution
and not just sort of more of what they
already know.
I think that's so important for you to
talk about it.
I'm so glad you do because for a
upcoming artists and in all sorts of
genres,
just people who were involved in
creating the here,
someone as successful as yourself,
talk about the various struggles of the
mind and,
and have momentum and the,
you know,
the different stages and various points
of your career.
So important.
Yeah.
The music meant his business plays this
jet I mind trick on you where the whole
thing set up to be patient and take
advantage of your weakness.
How so?
Well,
it's like,
um,
I,
I can use,
I'll use the music businesses and
example and I'm sure there's plenty of
parallels across the entertainment
spectrum.
Um,
you,
you struggled to get the contract and
then the contract is sort of,
you know,
the indirect indentured servitude type
of thing.
We,
our first contract was seven albums,
essentially 14 years.
So I signed that contract when I was 23.
That's crazy.
Okay.
So I'm signing a 23 years old and we
signed a contract that's supposed to
take me into 37.
You'd signing a contract for more than
half your life and if you look at the
shelf life of most artists,
it's for to.
So they're basically anticipating your
entire arc.
That's so crazy.
You don't have any leverage,
you know,
other than that,
they want to sign you.
He signed the deal and then it becomes
this weird dance of like,
can I sustain success?
Yeah.
If you get success and you have
leveraged,
they'll get out of your way because
you're making them a lot of money,
but the minute you're not making them as
much money,
then they step in and they start playing
these Jedi mind tricks on you.
We know.
What do you know the public's gonna
forget about you.
I mean,
I've heard all these things like,
you know,
this kind of weird like,
yeah,
you're in the room,
but you know,
we're the arbiter of whether you can
stay in the room.
That's the weird position that record
companies had for a long time that they
don't seem to have anymore.
My wouldn't.
I would argue against that because they
will do well.
They've moved to a different set of
circumstances and I'm not as conversant
as I as I once was,
but one thing they do with certain
younger artists,
but I think particularly more in the pop
realm as they do these three 60 deals
where it's like if you get a perfume
deal,
if you like your whole world,
we owned a piece of your whole world and
famous such a great quotion in American
life.
Now that you can see where kids would
trade fame and give and be willing to
give away,
like the the profit part will.
They'll take a risk
at the long term ownership.
Right?
So let me jump in there.
So if you actually survived the cut,
let's say,
let's call it phase one,
you're successful,
you're a name and now you're in a place
to either renegotiate or your deal is up
or whatever.
I once had a conversation with a very
powerful music executive and I said,
and I was friends with the guy,
so I was like,
give me the insider psychology here.
Now that I know the game that you run,
what do you tell people like me when
they get here and he says,
oh,
it's just,
there's always a price.
So they know that even if you get
through the matrix of the whole thing
and get off the other side,
that there's just a dollar amount that
will buy you back in.
Whoa.
They're not worried that you'll go
independent.
And in fact if you look at a lot of the
machinations of the music business over
the last 20 years,
especially with the rise of the
Internet,
it's to keep people in the system yet
they don't want true independence.
Right?
But it seems like,
look,
I'll give you a look no further than the
deals that the record labels cut with
the streaming services.
They got into ownership equity deals
with the streaming services in an,
in an,
in an arrangement for them to have an
equity position.
They agreed to very low rates for the
artist's music.
Ah,
so,
so when you,
when you listen to Bob Dylan Song on
spotify,
Bob Dylan's not getting a lot of money
for that,
but as spotify and the other streaming
services raise up in their equity
position,
the labels benefit.
So the labels pimped out their own
artists to take a greater equity
position in a rising business.
It's like,
you see what I'm saying?
Yeah.
They weakened the artist's position to
take a better position at the table
themselves.
That is fascinating.
And they,
they weakened the monetary position of
compensation in order to get equity in
the company.
Right?
And now,
and now you see it where a metallica's
management for example,
has come out.
And,
and,
uh,
especially,
Youtube,
former manager Paul mcguinness come out,
they're trying to take on youtube now
because youtube has got this weird funky
position where they'll pay on licensed
music but they won't pay for covers.
And you know what I mean?
Youtube.
So like one of the big targets of the
business,
because whatever deal they agreed to
with youtube 10 years ago is super weak.
And,
but again,
these are all machinations that go on
above the artists spot and quick thing
into your,
into your world.
When Mcgregor leaped out and did the
fight with mayweather,
he creates this whole different set of
dynamics because he's,
he can,
he can run his own game.
Yes.
UFC can't pay him.
That kind of money.
And last I heard is like maybe it's
going to do another fight.
So I'm not,
I don't want to get totally into that.
But my point is as you see where those
dynamics,
where people step outside the system,
it changes the game.
So it's actually kind of,
you could now,
now,
and I don't want to,
you know,
I've never met Dana White,
but if Dana white could go back in a
time machine,
maybe he'd pay mayweather,
Mcgregor more money to keep them in his
world because now that he's out,
I don't think connor would have accepted
that.
Okay.
But I,
you recognize the unique opportunity
that he's in.
So he probably wasn't any upon talking
about stuff as a fan,
the other side of fence.
But my point is,
is when you see,
when somebody breaks out of this sort of
the matrix of how the game is set up,
right,
it creates this weird thing.
Yeah.
And they have a few today though that
have kind of figured it out through
youtube and all these different online
chance.
The rapper,
I don't know much about his business,
but I know he's sort of worked out this
other model for himself that Jamie knows
a lot about them.
I know he's getting money from a way
other places than just the traditional a
record contract.
Big deals from major companies like
sprite another and he's still
independent,
right?
Tech technical word.
They would use to monitor him.
Like he's an independent artist,
but he's got a Michigan behind them.
So I don't know if he's independent,
you know,
I'm good friends with Sturgill Simpson
and sturgeons tried to educate me as to
how the record business people in,
in the fold with the owning your
merchandise and your likeness forever
and all these different things.
It seems.
It seems crazy.
We actually,
we actually signed a clause.
It is.
It said in this contract pertains to
this universe in any universe,
not yet discovered.
What would we signed that clause?
Who wrote that?
The record company.
Jesus fucking what do they scientology.
That is crazy.
Like we literally had a sign
thinking it was like this contract
pertains to this known universe and any
universe.
Not yet.
I
discovered that is fucking insane.
That is insane.
Like if someone found a parallel
universe somewhere and they figured out
they could sell music to them,
it's apparel.
They haven't heard the smashing pumpkins
get over there quick shoot a rocket ship
filled with cash
over there that,
you know,
why they put that in is because the,
when,
when they transitioned to cds,
the contracts didn't account for cds and
what they did,
it was a very uh,
it's a very classic thing is.
So they had to go back and renegotiate
all the deals because of the CT
technology.
This would have been like whatever,
eighties.
So they went to every artist and they
said,
look,
it's this new technology,
we're not sure it's going to work.
So you've got to take a price cut.
We're only going to pay you seventy five
cents on the dollar so we could advance
the new technology.
Oh Jesus Christ.
They're dirty,
they're dirty.
The spotify thing is dirty.
The uncomfortable hearing,
how they weaseled that,
how they negotiated cheap prices for the
performers.
Then they got an equity position in the
company so as the company grows because
they don't have to pay much and they get
all this music,
they get money from that.
That is sneaky.
Dark fucking.
Hey,
three d chess shake,
game of thrones,
man.
It is game of thrones,
but I mean obviously it's,
it's an,
it's an organism surviving in the face
of Napster,
right?
Like napster comes in,
file sharing comes in and they're like,
Holy Shit.
Okay,
so the Internet is just out there wild
and free and you can just download the
music.
That music is now digital.
We can't control it and it's just going
and it drives some people crazy.
I had Paul Stanley in here and you can
see the fucking anger in his face when
he's talking about people stealing
music.
Yeah,
I,
I was one of the first people that came
out for napster because I thought the
music business shit get in bed with
napster and Ssa,
let the monster grow.
Right.
I thought they should've brought napster
and house and made it like a given them
a per whatever.
Yeah.
But I mean if you want to be technical,
I mean the thing I helped support,
I mean it probably costs me $30,
million,
$40,000,000.
Napster did.
Yeah,
that whole world.
sure.
Yeah,
yeah.
I would imagine.
I'm not,
I'm not here to bitch.
It's like the world went on and I'm not
the only person,
you know what I'm saying wasn't targeted
at me and I supported it,
so I got nothing to say,
but I mean,
yeah,
at some point when you can't pay your,
you know,
your stupid mortgage on your fifth
property,
you know,
sad to Disneyland,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
I wish I had that money,
but it's a weird dynamic of,
of the Internet,
of,
of the free access of information.
And then when a song,
it's your creation can be boiled down to
information.
It's not that much different than
forwarding an email in terms of
people's.
The reason I support it in the beginning
was I thought that the free association
with music would create a more holistic
fans finding what they want and that we
would do well in that ecosystem that
turned out not to be the case.
Um,
and I,
I think now that it is sort of set up in
the streaming service world,
now that's starting to be the case
because people are finding us because
it's sort of organized and they're sort
of institutional culture.
But when it was free wielding,
um,
I don't think we played the game well
enough to take advantage of it.
And,
and a lot of trains just passed us by.
Yeah,
there was a lot of argument that people
would find new music because of that in
a way that they would have never found
if the record companies and the radio
stations had a lock down on what got
district.
Somebody did a study.
It's my one piece of empirical evidence
like the British,
the British Association of something,
when it first became a real issue,
did a study about people's fidelity to
artists,
whether they got something for free or
they paid for it and they found the
loyalty was literally know if they got
it for free,
that the actual act of purchasing
something created a relationship that
then created a sort of a desire to want
to prove that the relationship was
profitable.
In essence,
I buy your your comedy concert.
I didn't get it for free.
It makes me actually assess whether or
not my.
My thing was a good investment and if
you prove to me it is,
I become more loyal to you because now
we're in a relationship.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
Like you want to justify your purchase.
It also makes sense.
Like when I was coming up and we do
comedy clubs and they would pay for the
room and you know,
have a giveaway free tickets.
Oh God.
Right.
Audiences were terrible.
They were terrible.
You would think that people would be
thankful they got a free show.
Nope.
They were the worst.
Most unappreciative audiences because
they didn't have anything invested in
it.
That's it.
It totally makes sense.
So you saw it coming,
you saw napster coming,
you looked at it and you were like,
this is something that is inevitable.
We should probably figure out a way to
to.
Yeah,
there's some piece of them.
There's a piece of video me from like 99
where I say the future of music is
streaming.
Yeah.
Damn,
you called it.
They put me in some documentary.
I haven't seen it,
but I've heard about it.
Yeah.
I've always wondered like,
we're not on spotify or would this
podcast,
but they have.
They have podcasts on it,
but I'm like,
well,
where's the money?
Where's it going?
Like you,
you want me to be on.
Right.
But where's,
where's it going?
Well,
that's it.
And I usually using Amazon example,
remember for years the wrap on Amazon,
was there not a profitable business?
Nobody could understand because it was
this new model will now you understand
that that business model is about,
uh,
a growing the brand value.
Yeah.
You know,
in essence,
if you grow the brand value your,
your net worth as a,
as a brand.
It far outpaces whether or not you're
profitable.
Hm?
Does it make sense?
Yes,
it does.
So that's part of my argument now with
music is the brand,
and I use my brand smashing pumpkins or
the Nwa is far more valuable than my
sort of profit loss on paper in the
world of the open market.
And so as long as you appreciate that,
you won't let people come along and gut
out your brand value.
That's a fascinating of looking at it.
I don't think very many musicians
probably no,
because they're were surrounded by
people who are telling them it's a
profit loss business full well knowing.
I would argue that they,
they kind of know deep down to really
isn't like a.
let's use a good positive example right
now.
Gnr reformed,
you know duff and an excellent slash are
out there.
I just saw them at Madison Square
Garden.
I mean that's proving to be a very
durable brand right now.
You could argue how many wrecker,
if nobody cares anymore,
that's a durable brand.
The GNR brand or the Harley Davidson
brand or the Joe Rogan brand,
those are durable brands that,
that are worth far more than you could
sort of prove on paper.
The GNR ones is fascinating.
One to me because actually just went off
the rails and into the woods for so
long,
shooting his face up with a bunch of
shit and it looks like he was just gone.
It looks like we lost him.
Mean to me,
you as a kid.
Guns and roses like.
I mean they were like welcome to the
jungle is like one of my all time
favorite songs and I was like 18 or
whatever.
I old I was.
When it came out,
I mean it was amazing.
And then to see them just have this
incredible success and then actually
goes crazy.
But I would argue,
and I don't mean this in a disparaging
way,
I would argue that the freedom in axle
and the path that they took is added to
the brand.
I think so too,
because they're back.
I would argue differently.
I think that when you look,
and I'm speaking as a fan now,
when,
when I look at acts rose,
ifc,
a free person that means more to me than
whether he did the right thing in 2000
X.
I'm more interested in that.
That's a unique perspective.
So you liked the fact that he didn't
give a fuck and he just went crazy.
I love that about axl rose.
I love that.
He doesn't give two fucks about eight.
I think that's so fascinating because
there are true.
There are only a few American iconic
artists that are truly free.
Yeah.
And the fact that,
so it was hunter Thompson Thompson free
or you know,
it's like we only have a few of those
people.
Yeah.
Johnny cash.
Johnny cash had some weird bad years and
yeah,
you know,
was every year of Johnny cash perfect.
Was every year of Neil Young.
Perfect.
It's the sum total of what that person
represents.
That I think is the durability.
So we as fans,
we get into like,
well,
I don't like the new song or it.
I think that misses the mark.
There's only one guns n roses in the
whole world and I have fought mightily
internally to to protect what the
smashing pumpkins means.
I know it's not for everybody,
but there's only one smashing pumpkins.
I know that.
I knew that as a kid and I got a little
lost in it and I've come out the other
side and I realized that protecting what
that brand is worth is is so much more
valuable than whether somebody liked one
song or one album or something.
I said in 1992,
it's so inconsequential.
That's such a unique perspective.
When you look at Axel rose from the
point of view of being a fellow
performer to what I.
One of the things I really enjoy about
axl rose's.
I love comebacks.
I love when someone fucks their life up
and then just brings it right back
around.
I mean,
it's like a good fight,
right?
Well that's like every success stories
are awesome.
Love them,
but they're fairly commonplace,
but success complete fuck up.
Success again.
Those are the stories.
Those are the ones I enjoy and it's
very.
It's very American,
you know,
we,
we love the comeback and there was some
performances of axles when they were
attempting to come back or maybe he was
touring on his own.
I forget which one it was,
what he was like off and it wasn't quite
there yet.
And now you see him now live and he's
fucking killing it.
It's like he turned it around.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying is you could sit
there and talk about what somebody did
in some year passed,
but if they,
if they put it back together,
they put it back together.
Not because they're trying to,
to,
to satisfy something.
They're putting it together because the
forces within them are not easily
controlled,
but when there,
it's like a good fighter,
right.
When they,
when they put it all together,
you know,
I've heard you talk in commentary.
It's like a good fighter,
like manages their adrenaline,
manages their,
their focus,
you know what I mean?
You can't go completely hog and you
can't be too conservative.
You're right on that line.
Yeah.
And that's what performance really is
like.
It's like a lot of people outside the
bubble have a hard time understanding
this like,
you know,
every night I stepped on stage,
I want to do a good show.
Sometimes it's just not there to be had.
It could be the moon or it could be what
I eat for breakfast.
I don't know if I could be consistent
about it.
I don't think that makes me as
fascinating as somebody who's like
rolling the dice every time I'm up
there.
Yeah,
I think that's much more interesting.
Well,
that's one of the things that makes live
shows so unique,
right?
Is that you know that this guy is doing
it right now.
It's all happening.
The words are coming out of his mouth.
He's managing this moment apparently.
Yeah.
I mean,
when you're a successful performer like
yourself and you see one hit wonders,
one hit wonders of always freaked me the
fuck out,
and I don't know why I'm not even a
musician,
but just the horror of being successful
and hitting and then it all going away
and then you're fucked.
Yeah.
I was terrified at that.
God has got to be so scary.
That's,
to me one of the more,
one of the weirder opportunities or
moments in pop culture is when that kind
of stuff happens because with one song,
you know,
she's my cherry pie.
You can just shoot to the top of the
charts.
Didn't they have two hits though?
I think they had a couple.
Right.
So there to hit wonders.
Yeah.
But yeah,
there's a gang of bands that had.
Yeah,
I don't want to say the band,
but like somebody I know went to see one
of those one hit wonder type pants and
they,
they did their big famous song and the
crowd went crazy and then,
you know,
they didn't see it at the show and then
back on for that recording
they did the song again the same side.
Yeah.
And that's like for me it's a
performance.
It's heartbreaking.
It's like it'd be like me playing today
twice or something and here it is again.
Yeah.
That's two versions of stairway would be
like the dice man coming out and doing
the rhymes again.
Yeah,
yeah.
The thing about becoming a character,
what you were talking about,
that is,
that is a fascinating trap that I could
imagine we'd be difficult.
The expectations of your fans,
you know,
I just love the fact that you've managed
that.
So,
uh,
so comfortably with Coke Cardio,
a lot of people not having,
but I'm uncomfortable with it.
That's all that matters.
I would argue that that's true.
I'm like,
you know,
the plant,
I planted these acoustic shows and you
know,
at some point people start shouting out
songs and I,
and I just say to the audience,
look,
the great thing about turning 50 so I
don't give a fuck what you want to do,
what I want to do.
And at the end of the day,
right,
that sells better.
So most of the audience,
because most of the audience I would
argue,
appreciates me being independent even if
they don't always get what they want
than being a shill.
Yes.
I don't think people get behind rebels
because they want them to sell out.
They get behind rebels because they want
him to stay real.
Rebellious.
Yes.
Well,
yeah.
For every person who yells out,
I want you to do your old stuff.
There's many more people that just want
you to be you.
Yeah,
I would hope.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I would think so.
Yeah.
You're doing really intimate places like
youtube in that Hollywood cemetery is
pretty well playing the cemetery and my
friend Duncan used to do comedy shows
out of there.
Oh really?
They do comedy there.
They used to duck.
It's crazy though.
I don't think anybody else did it
before.
Now he just decided it's a bit strange,
you know,
just weird that they have a concert.
Like we couldn't sound check until a
certain time because there were people
in a bereaved.
People coming in to make their funeral
arrangements.
Yeah.
So it's like a weird thing like yeah,
we can't sound check till 5:30
because there's somebody in the anteroom
making burial arrangements for their
family.
Yeah.
Legitimately.
Like it's a real cemetery that also has
concerts.
Yeah.
How many does it seat to 50.
Oh,
well it's really small.
It's a cool vibe.
It's beautiful.
I mean it's really cool.
It's,
I love the old Hollywood stuff,
so you know,
works for me,
but it is a bit weird.
Yeah.
I literally texted,
you know,
like an ex girlfriend,
like I'm literally playing a cemetery,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
it just sounds so,
like what?
Yeah,
what,
what chose you or what,
what made you choose that venue?
Uh,
that's,
you know,
you got your,
your agents sort of,
you know,
when you're playing.
I'm playing acoustic tour.
I played over two hours literally by
myself.
No help.
So environment helps a lot with kind of
creating the atmosphere to do that in
the more sterile the environment,
the less it feels kind of special.
Right,
right.
And so I do find the environment
certainly helps.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a small group of people to see
you.
Like what is that like to go from these
big venues to doing these intimate
setting.
I used to really find that I could play
a different show,
small versus big.
And I've found over the last 10 years I
blamed the Internet that almost every
audience is now the same.
Wow.
That the expectations of the audience
from 2:50
to 5,000
or up is almost identical.
That may be have also have something to
do with just having a long career and
then people kind of say I want to see
these songs or something,
but I don't find as much willingness to
take the journey,
uh,
used to be because we,
we,
you know,
in the nineties who would do shows in a
club and we would play no hits and just
play weird besides.
And people loved it because it was like,
I'm seeing the band,
I wouldn't get to see it the normal
down.
And then at some point that stopped and
we would play a small club and play a
bunch of weird stuff and people would be
furious.
Yeah.
You would look at twitter after it was
like,
fuck you,
you ruined my night.
Oh,
it was really furious.
Wow.
But how many of those people were.
I mean like if you're in front of 400
people,
how many of those people were furious?
Is it three?
It would be a lot.
No,
it'd be awhile.
it was a lot strange.
Weird,
yeah,
I just,
I don't know,
I think it's a cultural thing.
Maybe it's a generational thing.
Perhaps.
Don't know.
It surprised me because I grew up in
this kind of anarchy time,
you know,
Mosh pits and you know,
we used to play a 45 minutes on religion
playing a 45 minute song today.
I mean a 45 minute song.
That's crazy,
you know.
So what do you,
do you enjoy being on top of people like
that?
Like a 250 seat.
It doesn't bother me.
It doesn't bother me at all.
Does it feel different?
What did you just get into your music in
order to play acoustic?
I go super within.
I,
I found that even because I originally
was going to stand in this I know seems
kind of minor detail,
but I decided to sit and,
and I actually found by sitting and
being very still and just performing and
doing my best job of performing the
songs,
the audience enjoyed the show better.
Like I took out all the show Showbiz,
you know when you're standing,
you're doing the.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
whatever your moves,
I think creating a level of intimacy and
drawing the audience forward is probably
the only sort of difference maker that
I've found because there's literally no,
there's no showbiz.
I'm,
what can I do
you seem very concerned with like you,
you want the audience to enjoy it.
Yeah.
I didn't use to care.
I,
I used to view performing as an art
project thing,
which is I want to sort of create a
provocative situation and then I want to
ride the wave of the provocative
situation.
And um,
and of course I grew up in a
generational thing that the audience was
sort of interested in that sort of the
explosive nature of the mosh pit and you
know,
this kind of weird sublimated violence
that would kind of come out during the
shows and we were part of the engine
that would sort of bring up this
emotional quality.
And then at some point,
you know,
things change.
Again,
I don't know if it's a generational
thing,
but I found that um,
the only I could play older music with a
good heart and an open mind was to get
into the others,
appreciating it because if he asked me,
it's not for me anymore because in
essence is an artist and,
and I'm not trying to jump in your head,
but as,
as an artist,
I want to be able to say how do I feel
tonight and tonight I want to,
I've written like 400 songs.
So to me I would like to say,
okay,
of these 400 songs I just feel like
playing these 15 songs tonight,
but I can't do that because I do have to
go out and do the Hickory dickory dock
poem.
It's like,
it's,
it's sort of,
it's sort of expected.
And if I don't I'm going to get lit up.
Right?
So I had to kind of create this weird
truce in my mind where it's like,
what way can I do this material in a way
that feels heartfelt and genuine?
And I found by letting myself appreciate
the audience's appreciation of that
created like a joy that I didn't have
before.
It didn't feel like a defeat and uh,
and a tapping out to the,
to the moment it felt like,
oh,
okay,
we can create this exchange.
Was this a gradual process?
Took me,
it took me awhile because I came from
such complete anarchy that does sort of
put myself in the straight jacket of
being a,
you know,
growing up in the air.
I grew up and it felt like putting on
the gold lamay jacket and going to
vegas.
That's what it felt like to me.
You know,
it felt like I was really,
you know,
I,
I'd become,
you know,
one of those guys,
doing the musty old routine.
It was like this is so antithetical to
why be even became an artist.
But at some point,
again,
I had to appreciate that.
Um,
and I talked about it once with Pete
Townsend in private.
It's like the idea that,
you know,
what is your responsibility to a
generational memory?
Like Pete was talking to me once about
how people were getting mad at him for
using a and I saw him quoted publicly so
I don't feel like I can.
I'm giving anything away.
People are getting mad at him for using
like won't get fooled again in a car
commercial and Pete's quote was
something along the lines of like,
I don't care if you lost your virginity
to Mary Lou in the back seat to my song.
It's my song.
I can do with it what I want.
So it takes time to sort of appreciate
that at some point if you've been lucky
enough and it.
And I am lucky enough to have created a
few kind of cultural milestones for a
generation or multiple generations that
they feel very possessive of those
things.
And so if you're not willing to possess
them with them,
it almost feels like to them you're
rejecting their idea not your own.
Oh Wow.
See to my mind,
I'm like,
well,
I'm the author.
If I don't feel like playing that song.
I mean that's my,
that's my decision.
So you sold them on something and then
if you're not buying anymore then it
almost feels like you're rejecting their
approval.
Yes.
Yeah.
And when you're surrounded by a bunch of
sycophantic artists who are literally
tripping all over themselves to give the
audience what they want to create.
This kind of idealized isn't this
amazing feeling and we've all been to
those shows.
It's the greatest concert ever.
And then you go to the next show and
it's the exact same lines in between the
songs.
It's Vegas,
right?
Yeah.
I mean capable of that.
So my way of feeling like you.
But my appreciation of that was to try
to get inside the head of why the
audience needed that from me because it
felt burdensome.
Like why me like get it from the guy
over there.
Like there's plenty of people you can
get this vibe from.
Why me?
Well that's the nickelback thing,
right?
Like people demand sincerity and if they
think that you're in like nickelback not
that bad,
but there are the fucking punchline of
punchlines when it comes to bad,
bad music.
And to me,
the guy's an incredible writer.
I mean Chad,
I mean he's an incredible songwriter.
I like their songs.
I liked some of their music.
I do,
I know it.
Some of it is like cliche subject matter
and I don't care of.
There's a lot of great songs that have
cliche sub subject matter,
but I don't,
I don't think there's anything I.
and I'm not trying to.
I don't know enough about their world,
but I don't think there's anything wrong
if that's who you want to be.
Yes.
Pop to me is predicated on unsatisfying
pop.
I've said it many times.
Pop is pouring,
it's pouring and want to get you off.
Right?
Right.
And it's,
it's just,
you know how they're going to get you
off.
That's a good way of looking at it.
Okay.
I'm not that concerned with getting you
off.
I'm just not.
It's just not in my DNA.
I was never that guy.
So to.
So at some point,
you know,
pick your age,
41,
you got some guy tapping on the shoulder
saying,
hey,
I need you to be that guy.
You're like me.
Have you looked at me lately?
I mean I'm not that guy.
He's a very strange so I had to get
inside the head of why people needed
that,
like what that did for them and sort of
a very general level.
It's sort of,
it's a,
it's a community thing or something.
Yes.
And so there's a way to do it where it
feels good,
positive,
loving and,
and,
and proportional.
Like it doesn't have to be slobbish and
it can be cool like okay,
this is the right moment for it or I can
set this up and now I can do it.
Like using the dice man as an example.
I've seen him a couple times.
I laughed my ass off when I saw him and
when I saw him he did his whole routine.
He showed up at the comedy store one
night I just happened,
would they be there with a friend?
And he did it like an unannounced
appearance.
He was fantastic and at the end he kind
Kinda,
he kinda of made the face and like.
And then he went into it,
but it felt like it was the only way he
could stop the moment.
Right.
So it right.
In that moment it felt like,
okay,
this is cool.
Because it's like,
it feels like,
hey,
you've been good.
We ate the whole cake together.
Here's the cherry.
Yeah.
But when it feels like I got to do this
because that's the gay.
I don't know.
I went through that whole process
himself.
Like he abandoned the rhymes for a long
time,
didn't even kind of try to abandon the
character a bit.
I have a little bit of a memory of that.
He did a television show,
like a regular sitcoms,
and he cried on some TV show like
Arsenio Hall
or something like that,
about people angry at him for being
controversial.
And I don't remember the early days of
political correctness when TV first came
around.
Yeah,
yeah.
It was A.
I think it was a little bit of a trap
that he felt like he was in.
And now I think in a similar fashion,
maybe similar
and using him as a sort of a.
As an example,
how many comedians have actually risen
up to that site?
Guys?
Level on almost none.
I mean it's been like a handful.
He was hot as you could be ever.
So paralleling my own self in that way.
It does create this weird
cause cause the 20 percent who know
every song and and whatever and know
every nuance.
The other 80 percent they just know the,
the greatest hits thing.
It's not their fault.
It feels weird.
Like,
is that all I am?
Right?
I've done all this,
you know,
didn't you see me when I wave this flag
and now they don't.
All they know is you're the rat in the
cage guy and you can be hostile about it
all you want.
It's not going to change.
Yeah,
I mean the amount of times I've been in
a parking garage or a grocery store or
whatever,
and somebody who's very nice,
very respectful will walk up to me and
that's what they know and if you can be
humble,
but I think it's pretty amazing that
literally I can get off any exit in
America and pretty much anywhere I go
somebody has some reference to what I've
done.
That's pretty,
pretty remarkable.
So if you can get behind that,
you can think,
oh,
that's pretty cool.
I'm cool with that.
It's,
it's not this oppositional thing,
like you should have paid more attention
in 94.
The Revolution was happening.
Where were you?
You were listening to somebody else,
you know,
like there's requirements.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And I installed so part and parcel to
when you take a,
a fringe movement,
which,
you know,
alternative music,
grunge,
whatever it was,
and it's thrown into the mainstream,
those social codes and mores don't
translate very well to mainstream code.
Yeah.
If you look at what people have done in
the last 10 years,
they just steal that stuff.
They take this coat and they take this
walk and they take this stance and they
take this production style and they say,
I'll take that.
Yeah.
They just combined it all together.
Yeah,
because it's because that's their gig.
I've always wondered what it's like when
you are.
When you're beginning as an artist,
you know you're,
you're idealistic.
You have all these ideas about what the
future could be.
Who knows?
It's all wide open and then all of a
sudden,
many years later,
you are a fucking massive superstar
selling out arenas.
How difficult is it to find people who
understand where your head is
impossible.
Do you like seek out other superstar
musicians?
And.
I did and I got nowhere.
It.
They're either really.
I've had a hard time ever getting like
good data,
let's put it that way.
The freakiest was.
I saw how it changed my inner world,
meaning friends and family,
how so?
My step grandfather,
who was a world war two vet,
very closed down,
classic Eisenhower,
Republican type of guy,
smart.
You know what I mean?
Had literally zero interest in me as a
kid.
I mean,
negative zero interest and,
and one day I'm sitting there at
Christmas and now grandpa wants to talk
to me about the economics of my success.
Whoa.
And it's like,
like that got through to him because
some guy at work or somebody at the
church brought me up and it was like,
oh,
that's my grandson,
you know,
nothing about childhood,
childhood tiers did anything but that I
saw were warped the gravity in my
family.
And then you get the friend,
like,
you know,
you're different.
It's like,
yeah,
I'm different.
Of course I'm different,
you know what I mean?
You know what I mean?
It's like you got a million dollars in
my pocket,
you know what I mean?
I could buy,
you know.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
I one day walked into beverly hills and
paid cash for Ferrari and that's just
dumb stuff.
Like,
that's kind of awesome though.
Yeah.
I remember the people don't like the
idea of that.
I think it's funny,
right?
It's amazing.
You bought a Ferrari with money that you
had on you.
That's fucking crazy.
And it was.
And it was the classic story.
I walk in,
you know,
the guy didn't know who I was like,
so how are you going to pay for this?
And I was like,
cash
you have a brick with you was like,
Oh wow,
that's just an awesome thing to be able
to do.
So I'm saying you go from like literally
complete,
not abject poverty poor.
I had no movie.
Right.
You know.
And then one day I'm like throwing,
you know,
Geez,
around for dumb cars and let's also you,
you've reached such a high level that
there's nothing above that.
Like
I have the,
I have the antidote,
my manager who was,
you know,
we were with the Metallica guys at the
time,
he called me on like a Wednesday or
something and he said,
I can't say for sure,
but more than likely based on the calls
we're getting,
you're going to be number one this week.
Meaning melancholy.
And I,
I literally said,
is there a position higher?
Like I couldn't process that.
There wasn't like another step.
Couldn't keep going.
Yeah.
Well that's what I always wondered.
Like when you reach a certain level and
you're sending out these giant arenas
and you one of the biggest bands
literally ever look at one of the top,
100 biggest bands of all time.
Right?
Arguably.
Yeah.
If we're in there.
Yeah,
it's in there.
Yeah.
Where the fuck do you go?
Like it had to be this weird.
Yeah.
I would imagine the madness is the only
option.
Madness started becomes attractive at
that point.
God,
that's got to be so strange to be just
crushing it.
Selling out these giant arena is number
one.
Songs going now what?
What the fuck do we do?
Do we fade
away now?
We went crazy.
We just lost her mind.
It's like,
what happened?
What was the process?
Did you see it slipping away?
Or you see the madness and it became,
you know,
it's like,
it's like a bad relationship or bad
relationships.
You,
it becomes a lot clearer when you're
out.
You know,
at the time you sort of do your own
rationalization.
Like,
oh,
he or she's going crazy,
not me.
We all went crazy in four different
directions.
Wow.
And this and that.
And the great shame of,
of,
of my band was musically we were super
tight and we never disagreed on music.
It was like this weird phenomenon where
musically we were like totally in sync.
We could produce and write music very,
very quickly and it was always the other
stuff around us.
So that sort of ate at the core.
And then when we,
when we lost our personal relationship,
that's what diminished the musical
relationship.
But you don't know it at the time
because you sort of,
I don't want to say arrogance,
not the right word,
but it's like you have a sort of a,
you know,
you got a little bit of a thing in your
walk and you think you got the world by
the unit.
What and all good.
You think you can power your way through
anything because you have,
right?
You don't understand that you do
actually need the people standing next
to you.
I have such a greater appreciation for
my bandmates now that now that I've seen
what we actually did accomplish in ink
is surrounded by chaos.
But then we created our own cast and
then at some point it all blurs.
What were the things that fucked it up?
Was it the money and the fame?
And was it the tension?
Was it the ego?
Um,
I think,
uh,
we were,
we were like one of those bad.
I'm behind the musics,
the very early conversation.
I remember we had these managers very
early on in and they were coming to
town,
sort of courting us before we had a
record deal and one day they came to
town and they said,
can we just go out to breakfast with
you?
Which was weird because it was always
the whole band like democracy.
And they said,
um,
they said,
uh,
know who writes the songs?
And I said,
well,
I do.
And they said,
well,
that's gonna be a problem.
Like,
what do you mean it's gonna be a
problem?
And he said,
well,
songwriters and bands make a lot more
money.
So our suggestion is you should share
your songs with your band mates to keep
sort of a kind of a democratic state and
the use of examples of bands that did
it.
And I thought,
hell no,
I'm not on,
I'm not giving them my work.
I mean it's my song.
So they were like,
you don't understand,
you're gonna make a lot more money.
And I was like,
tough shit.
You know what I mean?
It's like live and learn kind of thing.
Why do they think you were going to make
more money?
Because it was songwriters get a quick
lesson.
Uh,
the songwriter gets paid separate
statutorily by the government than the,
than the actual copyright of the
recording.
So if I'm on Joe Rogan's label,
you pay the band for the recording,
which of course in that case would be
split four ways,
but you owe me a statutory rate as a
songwriter for the sale,
which I think these days is about 10
sentence.
So every record we,
where I was the sole songwriter,
I was getting ten cents that they
weren't getting a or eight cents or
whatever it was at the time.
So you can imagine over a gazillion
records sold.
It added up.
Yeah.
So I start pulling away financially,
you know what I mean?
But when you're a kid and you're 23 and
somebodies having this conversation with
you and you literally don't even have an
apartment,
right.
And somebody is trying to tell you how
you're going to make a lot more money.
It's like,
what does that mean?
Fast forward four years later and it's
like I'm making a lot more money.
So that's sort of SOS it organically.
So his discontent,
yes.
Whether you call it jealousy or not.
And then as I emerged as sort of the
tour and the big mouth in the band and
maybe the person who was most willing to
be controversy or whatever,
we'd get in a room with journalists and
they would just talk to me a and then we
get out of the interviews and that the
band members would yell at me for them
not being asked questions.
So there's like this weird thing,
like it was my responsibility to push
them more as stars or.
Yeah.
So it's not just about the music,
it's about being appreciated and
successful.
And now in hindsight,
and in fairness to them,
I didn't appreciate why it was important
to them because in their minds we're all
equal.
We're in the room together.
Yeah,
you write the songs,
that's cool,
but at least give me the social currency
of being recognized or you know,
or somebody would offer me alone a
magazine cover.
And if I was smart,
which I wasn't,
I should've said no only the band or
nothing.
But I was like,
sure,
put me on the cover.
I'll take it.
You know what I mean?
Right.
You probably would have saw thought they
would do the same thing if someone came.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And then of course it becomes tit for
tat than like a two of the band members
went on their own and made a record
deal.
Um,
without me,
they got somebody to give them a bunch
of money to start a label,
which they had every right to do.
You know what I mean?
So suddenly they're like making side
deals and it starts getting all that
weird business.
And right now again,
it's like an erosion factor.
You don't appreciate it from within.
There's a lot of compression,
there's a lot of money,
there's a lot of stuff going on and then
one day it's sort of hollows out and
then it's too late,
you know,
you can't just sort of sit down and have
a meeting and make it all okay.
Because the wounds are deep and in our
case,
I mean the wounds lasted for.
I didn't talk to darcy for 17 years and
I didn't talk to James for I think 16.
Wow.
So we'd met named in the heat was,
was real.
I mean we didn't.
There were lawsuits and all sorts of
stuff and it's such a common story that
I hope someone listens to this part of
your mission as well.
They won't.
It's just human nature.
Right.
Because I would,
it is power corrupts man.
Yeah.
And again,
no sympathy asking him today though.
I mean when's that?
It wouldn't today.
Like I feel like if you were in the
similar position today,
you'd have hindsight and your favorite.
Oh yeah.
No,
no,
I would,
yeah.
I mean,
and even talking about the band going
back on a tour and the possibility that
it's like I approach completely
different.
Yeah,
so that's what I'm saying.
Like power doesn't necessarily corrupt.
It corrupts if you don't know what the
fuck it's going to do to you.
Sure.
Yeah.
But again,
I'm not preaching for sympathy,
but the,
and I can't speak for the modern music
business,
but the business we're in in the
nineties,
we were surrounded by people who were
giving us wrong information.
Now were they giving us wrong
information on purpose or because they
weren't bright enough?
I don't know,
but we weren't getting the right
information.
Very few people actually try to sit us
down and say,
look,
this is going to be a problem.
Trust me,
you know,
it's like you're in there with the
hounds
just right.
And they probably don't have the time
for psychological management anyway.
They're probably in the middle of just
trying to figure out how to make money
off you.
And Maya is my understanding.
My understanding is they and I,
and again going back to the conversation
I had with the executive,
they just basically look in,
they say you've got four years if you're
lucky,
if you're lucky,
so why are they going to,
why are they going to spend a bunch of
time trying to hold your hand knowing
you're going to lose anyway?
What a crazy relationship between the
record labels and the artists.
It's similar,
I guess probably like the pit boss,
if you're,
if you're having a hot run,
it like roulette.
The pit bosses just like enjoy it now
because we're going to get it back.
That's what it feels like.
What percentage of musicians or musical
artists that get signed by a label and
put something out,
ever wind up having an actually
successful career?
Probably less than 10 percent.
Jesus Christ.
I would say it's probably even smaller.
A meat grinder of a business.
You would think like,
hey man,
we're on fucking warner brothers.
Dude.
We made it.
It's happening.
They're going to promote us.
They're gonna.
Push us.
They signed us
and,
and sorry to interrupt again,
but the other weird thing is the athlete
in the system I was in was even if you
were successful,
it was set up to make you feel like you
weren't successful.
Right?
Because that was the work.
That was the manipulation.
Yeah.
I once said to somebody who is a very
famous name in the business,
it's like you guys find a needle in the
haystack and then you spend the next 20
years telling them they're not a needle
in the haystack.
Right?
It's it.
What I'm trying to say,
and I'm not saying it well,
is you would think you would be
surrounded by people are telling you
you're talented,
you're special.
We want to help you because the more you
succeed,
we'll succeed and we'll all succeed
together.
It was the exact opposite.
It was like,
no,
you're dumb.
You're wrong.
No,
you're crazy.
Don't do that.
You're going to ruin it.
And then,
and even if you'd say,
I want to wear this hat,
okay,
I'm going to wear this hat.
And when it wouldn't work,
that's say see to listen.
Uh,
is that universal?
Have you heard that other musicians?
I have the same.
It
was universal because looking back it
doesn't feel personal to me.
It felt like I,
I,
you know,
use your bad analogy.
Pimp Ho.
I don't know.
Right.
It's a weird con thing.
That was my experience was a lot of con
jobs.
Courtney love a piece that she wrote
about the music business.
I'm sure you're aware of that.
Was she,
was it recent or.
No,
no.
Bunch of years ago where she was.
I think it was actually probably before
digital got really huge and it was a lot
of people thought she had a ghost
writer,
but it was really eye opening to a lot
of people that didn't know anything
about the music business,
where the money actually goes and how,
how much money has to be spent and how
little you actually make.
Even though if you sell a shit ton of
records,
you've never seen this spring.
2,000
actually is on salon.com.
It might have been one of the years we
weren't talking about.
They go,
yeah,
well it's
for people that haven't read it.
It's pretty eyeopening.
I've nothing to do with the music
business.
I've always been absolutely fascinating
as a completely objective observer.
Just looking at this whole thing seems
so crazy because it's if you do not get
signed and if you do not get promoted
until recently,
you had no chance.
They.
They literally controlled the rains and
the direction of your career.
Almost like an actor.
Like you can't make it as an actor
unless you get an audition and someone
chooses to put you in a film.
But like the Great Greek mythology type
myth thing that the music business has
made to critical mistakes over the last
30 or so years that led to its current
sort of reduce status.
One was they let mtv run a muck on free
content and when they tried to rein mtv
and MTV basically told him to take a
hike in the music business back down.
So when MTV stopped playing music
content,
there was nothing in the music business
could do because they'd given away all
their leverage to the to MTV.
And then the second was when napster
showed up and they acted like napster
was a virus,
that they just need us to stamp out,
not really realizing that napster was
just the beginning of a whole wave of
new technologies and new sort of social
interactions or something.
Those two critical errors lead to the
music business.
Reduced position.
And it's this music.
I mean music has been around forever,
but the music business has been around
100.
Yeah.
I think we're into 120 plus years of
recordings.
Yeah.
Amazing.
How,
what a iron fist they've managed to
control the business with and,
and to sort of wrangle the artists for
the most,
most
part.
Well,
it's weird.
Wizard of Oz,
you know,
don't,
don't look behind the curtain.
Have you ever thought about being on the
other side?
Yeah,
I have,
but I just don't have that much.
I'm actually,
that's why I'm more interested in
wrestling.
I think I liked that.
I like the,
even though it's this sort of weird
business,
I sort of liked that because it doesn't
have anything to do with music.
I have too much damage and too many I
don't think I could see clearly.
Does it make sense?
It's like,
it's still too weird for me.
Yeah,
no it does.
It does make sense when you first,
when I first to La in whatever
90 and had the meetings and you'd be in
that,
you know,
hit the office and the people with the
beards and everything and they'd be
like.
So when we put the product out and every
time they would say product,
I would sort of wince product,
like how can you call my art product,
you know what I mean?
And that's to them it's just,
it's cookies and toilet paper.
It's,
it's whatever.
And um,
and it's not to say they're not fans and
they don't appreciate or they don't
care,
but at the end of the day it's just some
sort of weird business,
you know,
and like all institutional cultures that
are sort of kind of corrupted their
court just send it runs on its own
inertia.
It's,
it just does.
When you see someone like chance the
rapper break out of that system,
do you think that that's a model that
can be followed or is he just like an
outlier?
No,
it's certainly a model that can be
followed,
but you know,
it probably works because he's so
talented.
It's like a weird combination.
I mean,
use the mcgregor example.
It's like how many Mcgregor's or are
there in the world and beyond being a
skilled fighter.
I mean the guys in a level talker.
Speaking from a professional wresting
standpoint,
the guys probably the best promo in the
world.
Yeah,
no,
he's the best as far as MMA guys and
it's also he has in this very unique
position where he has insane support
from Ireland.
I mean insane that you've never seen
anything like it.
I've been calling fights for a long
time.
I've been working for the UFC since 97.
I've never seen anybody like him.
I've never seen any support like the
support the Irish people have for him.
It's fucking crazy.
And you see the videos of when he fought
mayweather.
Not even where they fought.
They were in Mandalay,
bay,
Irish had flooded Mandalay bay,
the walkway from Mandalay Bay as you
walk towards the arena and towards where
they are exhibited ship,
there was nothing but Irish people
singing and it's fucking crazy,
man.
It's like,
who organize this?
No one who told him to start saying
things as organic as an Irish
descendant.
We know we've been waiting for a long
time for conor mcgregor.
Yeah,
man.
I mean poets and Bondo.
You know what I mean?
We needed a fighter in there to someone
who's fun.
Yeah.
But to see all those people cheer and
scream.
And I was talking to Daniel cormier
about it this past weekend and he's
like,
there's no one like him.
He goes,
because he loses,
he doesn't lose any support.
Like not.
It doesn't change anything and people
respect the fact that he took a chance
and fought mayweather like can.
Can I ask you a Fanboy,
a UFC question?
So it sounds like core may last Jon
Jones,
right?
Is that okay?
Any last [inaudible] Jon Jones was on
whatever,
right?
Yes.
I mean,
how does a guy like that?
I'm asking more of a psychological
question because he's obviously he's a
great fighter.
How do you sort of process that?
Well,
I mean you have to really wonder why it
hasn't been established.
What happened?
Right.
So there's a lot
of speculation.
I don't know if you know the recent most
recent speculation that I talked about
the other day,
but the most recent speculation is that
John might have snorted cocaine.
That was cut with creatine that was
contaminated with steroids because if
you look at the timeline,
I know you look at the timeline,
John loves some cocaine,
but if you look at the timeline of when
John tested negative and when John
tested positive,
it is preposterous to think that he
thought that he could take it and not
passed,
but the fight coincides with 10 days out
from his birthday party where he
apparently got blitzkrieg.
So it is entirely possible.
Right?
That,
and this is just massive speculation,
but we have done some research online
and found that there have been cases of
creatine that was contaminated.
We buy cheap creatine from China,
contaminated with steroids,
specifically the type of steroid that he
tested positive for and create is often
use to cut cocaine apparently,
so it is entirely possible that he did
blow and that blow had steroids in it
through the contaminated creatine and
gave it back to cormay.
So core me a lost.
The question is,
did he lose because Jon Jones is a
cheater or did he lose?
Because Jon Jones is an amazing fighter,
so the second one would be harder to
deal with because if you lost.
Because Jon Jones is an amazing fighter,
did coq 10 days out before their title
fight and kicked his ass and now they
give Daniel the title back.
It's very weird,
but that's why I was asking more as a
fan,
like a psychological perspective,
a real fucking lie detector test.
That's what we need.
We do not.
We,
we value honesty so much and there's
very little other than some rudimentary
observations they can make with Mri,
functional magnetic imaging,
a resonance imaging,
which do you want to be lie detect this.
Strap me up,
man.
That'd be a good podcast.
I try to tell the truth,
have you done that podcast as much as
humanly possible ever been?
Have you ever like,
have you ever thought about so and so in
a particular way at the opportunity to
expose things that I think are fucked up
about me,
but that one,
um,
I mean,
when it comes to like cheating in combat
sports,
it has such an intense significance to
it that's not,
it's not an option or it's not a,
it's not a factor in other sports is
that you can cause damage to your
opponent,
like physical damage that could affect
them for the rest of their lives.
Right?
Like that was the case with Vito
Belfort,
when he fought Michael Bisping,
he had kicked bisping and knocked him
out and bisping suffered a really badly
detached retina in his eye and went on
to have several surgeries and now has
oil in his eye.
Like if you look at his eye,
there's permanent oil to protect his
retina that he has to leave in there
until he decides to quit fighting.
And then I'll have another surgery on
it.
And the question is,
did Vitol or land that because he's
highly skilled,
or did he land it because it's highly
skilled and taking testosterone,
it's you're,
you're,
you increase your ability to cause
damage and that changes the game.
It's not like hitting a baseball.
If a guy's on steroids and he hits a
baseball and his team won or your team
lost,
I get how the team would be upset that
he's a cheater,
but it's just not the same impact.
It doesn't have the same ramifications
here.
Well,
especially when you're talking about
like the angle of the punch and 10th of
a second being the difference between a
glancing blow and a knockout.
Yeah.
And that's what's so crazy is like you
get into this fractional idea of what is
just [inaudible].
There's so many factors or speed.
There's the amount of energy that you
have.
And then their psychological factors
like confidence.
There's no,
there's no metric to figure out what,
what kind of an effect being juiced up
psychopath has.
Like if you're someone who like Vito
Belfort who is already highly skilled
and then you pump them full of steroids
and he comes out to like,
motherfucker,
like he just feels like he can't lose
and that he has so much confidence and
then all this skill on top of that,
the seat he's,
I hate to pick on him,
but he's my favorite example because the
difference between him on testosterone
and him off testosterone is so radical.
Like there has been these photos side to
side or the two of them together and
you're just like,
wow.
Like it's like they're one of them's a
destroyer.
The other one is a dad,
like he's a dad bod,
you know,
it's,
it's weird.
So if that's the case with John Jones,
will you want to pull it up as a related
breaking story right now?
Oh yeah.
There's two to breaking stories in the
MMA world right now.
But this one,
since you're talking about it,
Anderson Silva fails out of us.
UFC Shanghai main event.
Make sense?
He's 40.
What did he fail for?
A sample?
A sample b test that failed from October
26th collection.
Huh?
So it was a couple of weeks ago.
That's interesting.
From a sample beet test sample sample
collected.
Oh,
okay.
It didn't say the actual drug because
they don't test sample b unless sample a
is.
Well,
I'm not surprised.
This is the other thing going on.
Right.
Conor mcgregor jumps the cage at Bella
tour when he's seven.
Conference referee.
Mark Goddard.
Oh yeah,
I heard about that.
Definitely don't do that.
Yeah.
I don't know what that was about.
I don't know why he did that.
Yeah.
You liked that.
I've already.
I'm already booked in the main event.
How do you have time for that wrestling
stuff?
Just so I just make time.
Make time.
Because you enjoy it.
Yeah.
Love it.
For all this fucking emo kids that are
just massive smashing pumpkins.
Fastest.
There's so many of them that that must
drive them nuts.
Yeah.
That's part of it.
That's wrestling tough shit,
right?
It is what it is.
Yeah.
So to answer your question,
Daniel Cormier is an awesome guy.
I mean,
it really breaks my heart when I see
people get upset and boo him don't like
him.
I just don't think they know him and for
whatever reason he is mean to be
completely honest.
He's always going to be in the shadow of
the greatest light heavyweight champion
of all time.
And that's John John's the greatest.
I mean he's,
he's so uniquely talented and special
and just there's something about him all
across the board and part of his
partying and all that shit is kind of
connected to that because he's fucking
wild and it's one of the reasons why
when he fought shogun for the title,
he was 23 years old.
He opens the fight with a flying knee
who fights a legend like Mauricio Shogun
who,
uh,
who was one of the greatest ever and
pride,
former light heavyweight champion at the
time.
John Jones fights him,
is 23 years old and is opening move is a
flying knee that lands.
I mean,
he's just,
he's uniquely improvisational creative,
wild,
talented,
physically,
incredibly dominant,
very strong kind of crazy body for the
game.
Like,
yeah,
the long,
long thing.
Strong though,
he's not frail,
like the difference between John is he's
got long limbs.
Buddy has that strong wrestling base,
so even though he's a thin guy,
he's very physically strong.
Strange comparison to make,
but back in the day,
used to hang out a lot with Dennis
Rodman when he was playing for the Bulls
and he had freakish strength,
kind of similar bonding,
looked very long like you wouldn't look
at them and think muscles and Rodman
could pick a 250 pound,
may end up with one hand and lift them
over a rope.
I saw him do it at a club that was
acting up and Dennis just rich over.
The guy picked him up like this.
And then even people would remember NBA
fans.
Uh,
Dennis used to guard the guard shack one
on one.
Yeah.
And that was when chuck was,
what,
3:40
years Dennis.
And that was when they had the whole
thing.
You couldn't use your hand yet at the
elbow and all that stuff.
He got them one on one freakish
strength.
And you're like,
you look at him,
you think,
how is that possible?
Some guys just have that weird
[inaudible],
whatever that is.
It's a lot of times it's those long guys
to something is about long limbs and
leverage and it's like they have to,
if they have long as they have a certain
amount of muscle with that long,
those long limbs and longer than
average.
I mean,
look at this look.
Okay.
Freakish in this,
you know,
this is like the air I'm hanging out
with Dennis.
I mean,
look at Dennis this size compared to
Shaq.
You.
If you didn't know it was Dennis Rodman.
It was just some,
you know,
NBA Scrub,
right?
You would think there's no way that
guy's going to guard him one on one.
Especially Shaq in his prime there.
There's no way.
Yeah,
it's a crazy guy.
Interesting.
Speaking crazy.
I tell you a funny story.
You got a good story.
Yeah.
So used to hang out a lot with Dennis
and uh,
you know,
hadn't seen him for years.
Was at a restaurant in Chicago not too
long ago and um,
and somebody said,
oh,
you guys are friends with Dennis,
right?
Yeah.
Oh,
he's upstairs.
Oh really?
We go upstairs,
Dennis's crying.
Oh my God,
I miss you guys.
Me and my buddy were hanging out with.
I'm telling old stories,
you know,
seven or eight years,
haven't seen him.
This is great.
Like,
uh,
when you see a buddy you really love and
it's really affectionate and Dennis is
one of those people at some point he
just gets up and he wanders away.
I think he's going to take a piss.
Okay.
About 10 minutes goes by,
I say to the waitress.
To Dennis leave.
Yeah,
he left.
Okay.
I just figured he's gone.
It's just the way he is.
He wouldn't even say goodbye.
Just gone.
I get up the next morning I turned the
television,
Dennis Rodman's in North Korea.
I,
by the way,
I spent an hour and a half with them.
He didn't say anything.
We'd go about going in North Korea.
Right.
So I turned on the television.
It's like very controversial.
Dennis Rodman's in North Korea.
So I texted my buddy and I say,
have you seen the news now what I say,
turn on the television.
And he said,
what channel?
I said,
it doesn't matter.
Two minutes goes by holy fuck,
because he went through the same thing,
you know?
Wow.
Yeah.
What is his deal with that North Korean
dude,
he just goes over there and hangs out
with them and really a genuine,
uh,
you know,
a naive hearted person.
So in my best understanding is he truly
believes he can affect the world in a
positive way.
So there's dentists,
there's not a bad bone in Dennis's body.
Dennis has his issues,
but he's not a bad hearted guy.
So in his kind of crazy ideological
frame,
he actually thinks he's helping,
so he thinks he can go over there and
talk some sense into that guy or by
playing basketball open,
you know,
whatever.
He's.
Yeah,
I mean,
so that's not a good shot.
you know what I mean?
It's not a good look,
but yeah,
I mean he's hanging around with a
murderer as dictator hoping for the
best.
But that's what I mean about the
naivete.
And I don't mean to cache.
And Dennis,
I really loved Dennis.
It's been nothing but a total sweetheart
to mind to me in my life,
but I gen dennis would in a very naive
way believe that he's actually helping.
It's a very gangster move to go over
there though.
I mean it's just the other side of
Dennis.
It makes a certain sense.
It's like,
I'll do it.
Yeah.
I remember when he was dressing up in
drag and you know,
it's like,
I'll be that guy so it's somehow it's
sorta works in his.
Again,
I'm not trying to speak for him,
but he was one of my favorite guys on
celebrity rehab because he was working
out every day drinking water.
I used to go into the bowls locker room
after games and he would work out after
games.
Really.
We go in and go [inaudible],
we're going to go out clubbing or
whatever and you go in the locker room
and he'd be working out and we have to
sit and wait for him to work out for
another 40 minutes after the game.
And he played.
It wasn't like he was had a knee injury.
I mean he played the whole game.
Like what kind of workouts do you like
lifting weights or something treadmill,
you know,
whatever,
whatever he was doing,
why I wasn't.
It wasn't like light stretching.
It was like the energizer bunny.
And then we go out and stay out all
night.
Jesus,
they quick.
You want a quick story?
So I'm hanging out with the bowls.
It's the first time they're playing
Utah.
Um,
they,
it's a very,
it's a,
it's a series of bolts probably should
have lost,
but they didn't.
It's the famous game where,
uh,
the famous series where Michael had the
flu and scored 36 points.
I know if you know that game,
it's one of the most famous games.
Michael legit had crazy flu and scored
36 and they won the game and they won
the series.
So in between one of those games,
Dennis knows some billionaire,
there's a day off,
we get on the billionaires plane and we
fly to Vegas.
We stay out all night gambling.
And this is Dennis,
like,
you know,
rubbing dice on people's bodies and
throwing the dice.
So drunk they're balancing out of the,
you know,
the craps pit.
And I mean just total mess and you're
thinking,
how is this going to help us win a
championship?
Very much a fan mentality.
I'm thinking naively I'm going to kind
of reign them in so.
So we stay out all night.
We'd get up,
we'd never go to bed.
We get,
we fly on the private plane,
back to make the morning press shoot
around back in Utah.
So we've only been,
we've only been in vegas for like eight
hours.
So 9:00
AM.
I'm sitting in the stands.
I haven't slept at all.
They do the whatever,
the shoot around and Dennis walks up and
says let's go back,
go back where the hotel.
No let's go back to Vegas.
So after the morning shoot around,
drove to the airport to fly commercial
because now the billionaires not sliding
them back again and gets on a plane
commercial and it's given me shit
because I don't want to go back to vegas
with him.
Jesus kron the off day and this is
during the NBA,
the NBA finals.
So through some sort of weird,
you know how the world works.
I ended up somewhere,
I don't play,
I go to play miniature golf or something
in Park City,
Utah where the bowls were staying and
Phil Jackson and his family's had just
happened to be there on like an off day
and Phil has given me the look of death
because I'm the one responsible for
dentists go into Vegas.
The rockstar dragged on the bad guy and
I'm thinking,
you don't understand.
I'm the one to tell him not to go.
I want to win a championship or at least
have one now.
What are you gonna say to Phil Jackson?
Have you ever met Phil Jackson?
Phil Jackson is an intimidating guy.
He plays very zen on tv,
but in person.
He's very intimidating.
Six,
seven,
six,
eight,
and he was legitimately upset at you.
Let's just say it wasn't a nice
encounter and I love Phil Jackson.
I mean,
I loved those years.
I love those teams and I was lucky to be
around them a lot.
I used to say,
look,
watching this teams like 19,
27 Yankees,
I mean you will look back very fondly on
this time and to even be in that bubble
at all and it was awesome.
But yeah,
I mean catch and shade from Phil Jackson
at the height of the Bolus thing.
It was just so funny and I'm playing
miniature golf and you know,
this is so uncomfortable.
That is hilarious.
Do you still keep in touch with Dennis
now?
Dennis is sort of.
He kind of tried it out into the ether
and I,
you know,
it's hard to follow it.
It under my thing.
It falls under what I call the celeb
friendship.
I've had various times had to.
I tried to have friendships,
legitimate friendships with very famous
people and the way they run their worlds
is.
I'm sure you've encountered.
It's like,
it's like you got to go through this guy
to talk to this guy and then the message
doesn't get through and I think,
oh fuck all that.
I'm not doing that.
Yeah,
I don't.
If I can't just text you.
I can't be friends with.
Yeah.
It gets into the weird thing of like,
you tell Larry the guy and then Larry
never tells the guy and then the guy's
upset at Larry,
but Larry's looking at you like,
yeah,
we had to go do this thing and I just,
I can't do any of that.
Yeah.
There's a few guys that are like that,
right?
There's a few.
It's weird.
It's,
I feel like when someone reaches a
certain level of success,
especially fame,
uh,
they,
they get people to sort of handle
certain menial tasks and then that
person sort of becomes their babysitter.
Yeah.
I have very few friends that are famous
and it's one on one.
Yeah.
Or forget it.
No,
the with David.
If I'm a fan.
I mean there are people I've,
you know,
I could call them up kind of thing that,
I mean they're like my absolute idols,
but if I can't have that rapport,
it's like,
forget it.
It's just,
it's almost too weird.
It's like,
because why then am I,
am I a fan guy hanging around hope and
he's going to throw me a bone and talk
to me about their second album.
You know,
and it's like it gets into that kind of
uncomfortable space.
You're,
you're making the same mistake.
I don't want people to make.
I don't want people around me.
Like some of my friends were in the
room.
They talked to me like I'm the guy from
Glendale Heights.
Like there's no star trip with me.
Like I want everyone to be straight up.
I don't want any of that.
I don't need it.
Well,
it's like what you said,
you're
talking about turning 50,
you know,
like you're 50,
you don't give a fuck anymore.
It's like that's one of the things I did
give a fuck before 50,
but now you have to declare it.
Yeah.
But it's great that you are willing to
be this guy and be yourself openly.
Because one of the things about music in
particular,
but I guess a lot of other areas of show
business too,
is that people really protect that
image.
They protect that brand,
they protect that,
that thing that they're projecting to
their fans,
they have this idea what their fans want
and they hold that really sacred.
But I think pulling the curtain back the
way you do,
I
think it's very brave,
but it's also very
port.
I've certainly had moments in my life
where I,
I wondered if I had it to do all over
again.
Like sometimes I'll,
I'll,
I'll riff with a,
like a,
a journalist that I know enough to sort
of riff with and I say because sometimes
they'll say like,
do you feel you're under appreciated as
an artist or you didn't feel you didn't
get to do you to serve?
And I'm like,
yeah,
that's absolutely.
And maybe everybody feels that way,
but I certainly feel that way.
And so my little funny,
a sec,
a blog question for them as if I'd never
opened my mouth and all you had on me
was my music.
Would you have a different opinion?
And they say they always say the same
thing.
Absolutely.
That's weird,
right?
Yeah.
So did my mouth,
you know,
boot me down.
Yeah.
Ladder.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
It's,
it's fun to play.
It's like a part of the game.
It's too late now.
I mean,
I think it's a different opinion,
but it's not a lesser or greater
opinion.
I mean,
my opinion of you is greater seeing that
you are very open,
honest.
But if I knew you,
like if I didn't know you have your
music.
Oh go.
Oh,
he's a regular guy.
He'd been.
A lot of people don't like that.
They don't like regular guys know.
It's a fantasy world.
Yeah.
That's part of the music business,
right?
Yeah.
I got to ask you this one thing for sure
is because I read this and I was like,
what?
Here we go,
uh,
you saw someone shapeshift Oh God.
Is it,
is that really where you fucking with
people?
That's true.
Really.
It's true.
Because when you told me joy Kaufman
like moments,
I was like,
okay.
No,
no,
it's true.
I would tell you off grade,
but I won't say it publicly.
Really.
The only way I'd say it publicly as if I
write it and I've been writing this book
for years and it's in the book really.
So I'd tell you off grid,
but I can't get.
Look,
I know Alex Jones sat in the seat,
right?
I know you've been on it for wars.
I've been in I think three or four
times.
Well,
what have you been on them for?
Is for.
I'm mostly talking about free speech.
I think that's,
I think that's one thing that,
that,
um,
is,
is critical and alternative media is to
fight that.
That's a frontline issue for me.
Yeah.
This demonetizing,
uh,
people's videos and trying to censor
messages and even how in to twitter exec
just recently admitted in front of
Congress how they were suppressing a
negative hillary hashtags and stuff.
I mean,
that's crazy to me.
Yes,
I think so too.
That like you got some of you openly
saying,
yeah,
we were,
you know,
if we're going to sit here and go on and
on about Russian collusion,
I mean,
is that not an in kind donation,
will you?
You're manipulating people's ability to
change it.
So as an artist who's been in the public
sphere almost 30 years and I've seen
people manipulate my image and turn me
into a meme and all this stuff,
I'm very sensitive to if somebody wants
to deny me the right to re to either
reply or get my message out,
right?
As long as we have that ability,
I trust our democracy.
We need people like you and me and
anybody else like great.
I think our democracy is better for it.
And that includes the people who say
things that I don't approve of or like
I'd rather have them say it than not
safe.
I agree as well.
And I think it's very important that if
people do say those things that you
don't approve of or like that other
people express why they don't approve of
those things are like them.
And the only way that happens is if you
hear the initial thought,
you have to hear the one thing that you
don't like in order for someone to say,
saying something that resonates,
you go,
yes.
That's why we disagree with that
initiative.
Okay.
So to use any personnel,
if we,
if we generally agree,
than an idea is so aborad or so racist
are so bigoted than what are we afraid
of because the argument should be that
the collective agrees that that is an
inappropriate thing to do and express
and then socially we can sort of correct
course and it gives the other person on
the other side the opportunity to course
correct to yes.
In essence,
if you're not,
if you're so sure of an idea of being
true,
what are you afraid of?
Why can that idea not withstand the
dirtiest most scurrilous thing that can
be thrown at it?
Yeah.
It's one of the more uncomfortable
things about people on the left today is
this newly embraced idea that you should
be able to suppress ideas you don't
agree with.
That's terrifying.
It is terrifying.
It's terrifying.
I agree.
I mean,
let's wrap this up so I could hear your
shape shifts or.
Sorry,
I want to Elena,
hear that man.
It's.
Let's put it this way.
It's pretty wild.
I believe you.
I just the people.
I will.
Someday.
You'll put it in a book.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
please tell people how they can see you,
the,
the name of your new album where they
can get it.
Uh,
I have an album out solo acoustic Oj,
Lala produced by Rick Rubin.
Um,
it just came out about a month ago.
I'm just finishing up my tour dates in
La,
so that's pretty much done.
I'm going to go record another acoustic
album and then hopefully next year
they'll be a pumpkin.
Stuart.
Awesome.
Our fingers are crossed.
Well,
thank you.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
All right folks,
that's it.